こんにちははじめ社長です前回のゴールの街で
ん筋肉痛があっ
やばいです工房全部でちょっと今日は
000プレビソーダー
ずのっ scars ねぇですん
黒柔らか
上野がルピせそこを誰にね普通の誰ペットクラブ何が違うかったら
時はするプレーにまとめますね上
方はぞせ悪いやってい
存在しますん
ん
燗映え
うん
深い8時ってどういう味卵がよくわかんないんですよね
いただきます
あれは
北郡
高3の時だったん
僕のば助けるの
物は大ステマしてん
僕が部ぞになればですごいうちの高校のバスケは元気がなかったんですよ
すごい練習も掲げてましたし試合もあんまり
結果残せなくていい
あんまり良くないと思って
で僕がキャプテンになってから猛練習のメニューを全部書いてすっごい走り込ませたり
スーパーの数を増やしたりしてもうしっかりしたが助っ人の7
したんですよ
うん
けどうちの
工房のコパスケブのコーンの先生が忙しかっ
なのであまり9月に来れなかったんですよ
も
20巻に1回来るか来ないかみたいな感じで
うん
そして
月日は変わり
良いんだいじゃあの日が近づき
その僕も不調で今まで練習してきていっ
力を出し切ろうと思って試合に臨んだんですけど
僕の県の中ねー best ii ろなぁで行ったんですよ
ベストはいいと宣伝 a
ほんのちょっとの差で負けてん
ご一家やしてるんでしょうか
絶対勝ちたいと思ってたし
ベスト8ってなったらやっぱり凄いじゃないです今まで無名だったのにいきなりベスト
atok だったらまあで絶対勝ちたいと思ってたんですけどほんのちょっと
つから及ばず曲げちゃったんですけど
その時
顧問の先生がん
最後僕に
何をした感じ入ったなぁ
ありがとうと一言
くれてうん
その後加工
握手してますよな感じで提案してきた戦艦
何かあっあーっ
高
ずっときましたねうーん
マネが多分先生なりの
母さんをすべて表すとアクセだったんだぞ
思います先生もうちょっと一緒に頑張りたかったんですけど
忙しかったりしてあんまり子
うつの部活で一緒にできなくて
まあその
最後の
真佐部僕初のないねん
しっかりしっかり1月に変えたんでいろんな意味上った
握手だったと思ったんですよとか
そういう感謝の医療前にされて
ちょっとウルッときました泥炭地なぁ2階へ
味のはカラービーズでしたらじゃねぇ
おめでとうございます
アズのレビューしてないよ
ん
うわぁ
普通のあるビーズです